[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذه العربيه 360
حيث الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
[موسيقى]
في افريقيا ويتحدث عن واقع امني تغير
والتقارير تؤكد حديثه روسيا ملات الفراغ
بعد جدل المبادره الصين بيلد الالمانيه
تقول ان الغربه يضغط على تقدم بحلول
الخريف او تفاوض
لمستوى القياده والمستوى الحكومه
الراكده اتفاق لتطوير العلاقات مع دمشق
وتنسيق للقاء يجمع السيسي باردوغان
لدينا ايضا
قلق امميه من مستوى العنف في الضفه يدعو
لتفعيل لجان الحمايه الشعبيه وتل ابيب
تتوقع اياما صعبه
[موسيقى]
دشن الرئيس الفرنسي زيارته الى افريقيا
بحمله هجوم على المنافسين لباريس في
القاره وبالاخص روسيا والصين مكرون انتقد
اولا مقال انه تقاعس من الدول في منطقه
الساحل عن كبح جماح المتطرفين وشدد على
انه لن يسمح بان تصبح فرنسا كبش الفداء
المثالي في القاره وقال مكروم انه يرفض
الانجرار الى تنافس عفا عليه الزمن بين
الدول للسيطره على افريقيا معتبرا ان قوات
فاجنر الروسيه باتت بمثابه تامين على
الحياه للانظمه الفاشله في القاره على حد
وصفه
اذا تنازع النفوذ بين فرنسا وروسيا على
افريقيا يدفع الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل
ماكرون للتوجه للقاره السمراء في محاوله
للابقاء او استعاده الهيمنه الفرنسيه ان
صح التعبير بعد ان كانت لها اليد العليا
خاصه في غرب القاره عانت فرنسا انتكاسا
عسكريه وسياسيه في بعض الدول التي تحولت
الى الشراكه العسكريه والاقتصاديه مع
روسيا الرئيس الفرنسي القى خطابا خصصه
الاستراتيجيات فرنسا الدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه في افريقيا قبل ان يباشر جوله
تشمل اربع دول في وسط القاره وهي الجابون
وانجولا والكونغو وجمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه في زياره تتركز على مناطق
بعيده عن المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه
التي باتت تتصاعد فيها المشاعر المعاديه
لباريس جوله الرئيس الفرنسي تاتي بعد اكثر
من اسبوع من قيام بوركينا فاسو بطرد
القوات الفرنسيه وانهاء اتفاق عسكري سمح
لفرنسا بقتال المسلحين في الدوله الواقعه
في افريقيا لتصبح احدث دوله افريقيه ترفض
مساعده باريس فالعام الماضي سحبت فرنسا
قواتها من مالي بعد ان بدا المجلس العسكري
هناك العمل مع متعاقدين عسكريين روس ما
انها 10 سنوات من العمليات ضد الجماعات
المسلحه في مالي وانتشرت مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه ايضا في جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى ما اثار مخاوف من تداعيات
على الوجود الفرنسي في القاره سبق ذلك
اتهام ماكرون لروسيا بتغذيه دعايه مناهضه
لفرنسا في افريقيا خدمه لما اسماها
الطموحات الجشعه لروسيا
يجب النظر الى الدول الافريقيه كشريك
اساسي تربطنا به مصلحه مشتركه يجب خلق
علاقه جديده متوازنه ومسؤوله حان الوقت
لاعاده تحديد طبيعه علاقتنا مع الدول
الافريقيه وعلينا ان نظهر تواضعا كبيرا
عندما نتعاون معها لدينا توجه جديد تجاه
الافريقيه وسنتعامل مع واقع امني جديد في
افريقيا
لقد قمنا طوال السنين الماضيه بدعم
شركائنا في افريقيا وتم تكريس اكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات يورو بين عامي 2019 و2022
في اطار الدعم للدول الافريقيه نعمل على
سياسه جديده للتعامل مع الدول الافريقيه
وسيكون وجودنا في افريقيا عبر قواعد
مشتركه مع الدول الافريقيه
الامريكيه نشرت تحقيقا حول انتشار مجموعه
فاجنر الامنيه الروسيه في افريقيا وقالت
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يسعى
لتعميق نفوذ بلاده في القاره وفي السنوات
الاخيره وسعت فاجنر بثبات نفوذها السياسيه
والعسكريه والاقتصاديه في افريقيا وفي
المقابل رفضت العديد من الدول الافريقيه
ادانه الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا او
الانضمام الى العقوبات الغربيه ضد موسكو
الصحيفه الامريكيه تابعت تقريرا سيصدر هذا
الاسبوع للامم المتحده قالت فيه المنظمه
الدوليه ان عناصر من مدربين ومقاتلين
عملوا مع جنود محليين في جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى لسن هجمات تهدف الى السيطره على
اربع مناطق على الاقل معروفه بمناجم الماس
مع دعم السلطات بالطائرات العسكريه ايضا
اشار مسؤول استخبارات غربيون الى ان
مجموعه فاجنر تدرب مجموعه مسلحه في تشاد
التي تربط حكومه البلاد علاقات وثيقه
بفرنسا في محاوله للحصول على موقع قدم في
تشاد وعلى الصعيد السياسي زار وزير
الخارجيه
فيما اعتبر مؤشرا على دفء العلاقات بين
الكرملين والحكومه العسكريه التي استولت
على السلطه قبل عامين وقال ان هناك فرص
التعدين لشركات الروسيه في مالي مشيرا
بالظروف المريحه التي يتم توفيرها للشركات
الروسيه العامله في البلاد واهمها مشروع
مشترك بقياده شركه فاجنر
ومعنى الان من باريس الصحفيه والكاتبه
السياسيه هدى ابراهيم اهلا بك معنا استاذه
هدى
رئيس وزراء المجرى فكره توسيع الناتو يقول
علينا التفكير الاف المرات قبل ان نوافق
هذا فقط خبر عاجل ولكن نعود الى موضوع
فرنسا مكون يتحدث او يبدو لي يمكن ان
تصححي لنا انه يتحدث وكان فرنسا يعني كانت
جمعيه خيريه في تاريخها لم تكن تستعمر
دولا بحالها وانه يلوم الروس الان على ذلك
بجيوشها ومرتزقتها كما قال في خطابه ما
رايك
استاذه هدى ابراهيم الكاتبه السياسيه
والصحفيه من باريس ارجو انك تسمعينني الان
كنت سالتك عن خطاب الرئيس ماكرون يتحدث
بلهجه ان فرنسا يعني تلوم موسكو على
جيوشها ومرتزقتها في القاره الافريقيه
وكان فرنسا كانت بتاريخها جمعيه خيريه ولم
تكن دوله مستعمره لعديد من دول وشعوب
العالم ما رايك
هل السؤال موجه لي نعم استاذه هدى
تسمعينني جيدا السؤال موجه لك
نعم لم اسمع البدايه لم اسمع بدايه السؤال
للاسف ساعيد عليك سؤال يتحدث عن ضروره
التواضع والتحلي بالمسؤوليه رافضا
المنافسه الاستراتيجيه ويقول التي يفرضها
بحسب قوله من يستقرون هناك مع جيوشهم
ومرتزقتهم يلوم الروس وينتقد فاجنر والى
ما هنالك وكان باريس كانت جمعيه خيريه في
يوم ما ولم تكن دوله مستعمره لدول وشعوب
عديده في تاريخها المعاصر القريب الحديث
وليس البعيد في الزمن اسالك عن رايك في
هذا الكلام
نعم الواقع ان الرئيس ماكرون لم يذكر ولا
مره لفقنر ولا روسيا وانما المح اليها الى
كليهما
فرنسا يعني
بغض النظر اذا سمى او لم يسمي قال جيوشهم
ومرتزقتهم وواضح قصد روسيا وفاجنر وكلامه
يعني
تفسر عده وكالات انباء بدون اي عناء يعني
واضح جدا نعم
بالطبع لكن قصدت من قول ذلك انه يريد ان
يقول انه اعلى من لذلك اعلى من ان يسمي
وبالنسبه لمساله التواضع هو يتكلم عن نفسه
ويتكلم عن ان فرنسا في السابق لم تعطي
افريقيا قدرها حين اقول في السابق يعني
منذ وصول ماكرون الى السلطه جميعنا يذكر
خطاب الرئيس ماكرون امام طلاب جامعه
وجدوغو عام 2017
ويمكن اعتبار هذا الخطاب الجديد تكمله
لذلك الخطاب مع بعض التغييرات التواضع يجب
ان ياتي من فرنسا هذا ما قاله لكن طبعا
هناك منافسه شديده اليوم لفرنسا في
افريقيا سواء على الصعيد العسكري او على
الصعيد الاقتصادي ماكرون في خطابه اليوم
اعترف بان لي فرنسا مصالح اقتصاديه كبيره
في افريقيا ولكنه في نفس الوقت قال ان هذه
المصالح يجب ان تمر عبر شراكه بين
الطرفين وشراكه مقبوله من كلا الطرفين هذا
يعني الى اي مدى فرنسا باعتقادك مكروم او
غير مكرون ستتمكن من المضي قدما في هذه
السياسه من تحقيق هذه السياسه مع التغيرات
الجيوسياسيه في العالم وخاصه تلك التي
فرضتها الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ماضي
باريس الاستعماري اولا
المنافسه الروسيه والصينيه الشرسه الان
لاوروبا ولا امريكا في افريقيا تفضلي
والتركيه ايضا يعني في كلام الرئيس ماكرون
كان هناك ما يرمي ايضا اضافه الى روسيا
والصين الى تركيا المتغلله كثيرا اقتصاديا
في القاره الافريقيه والتي تنافس فرنسا
احيانا بشكل اشد من روسيا واقول اقتصاديا
نعم
في الواقع قال ان
بلاده تعاني من التركه الفرنسيه التركه
الاستعماريه وهو قال ان الانسحاب الفرنسي
من بعض الدول نحن نعلم مثلا ان لفرنسا
قواعد في تشاد في النيجر في ساحل العاج
قواعد عسكريه هو قال ان الانسحاب من هذه
القواعد سيبدا في الاشهر المقبله وهذه
القواعد في المستقبل
وطوال الخمس سنوات المقبله فتره حكمه
تتحول شيئا فشيئا الى اكاديميات ومدارس
عسكريه يتم فيها التعاون بين كل بلد وبين
ويكون عدد الجنود الافارقه من كل بلد اكبر
من عدد الجنود الفرنسيين في هذه القواعد
الموجوده اليوم طبعا هذه وعود نحن سننتظر
ان نرى كيف تتجسد على ارض الواقع ولكن الم
تتاخر فرنسا في محاوله مواجهه تراجع
نفوذها في افريقيا ومواجهه النفوذين خاصه
الروسي والصيني وما العوامل التي ستؤدي
الى نجاح ماكرون في سياسته تلك في افريقيا
في دول معينه او تلك التي ستطغى فيها
روسيا بحكم الامر الواقع المستجد في
العالم
نعم فرنسا تاخرت كثيرا هذا حقيقي وهذا
واقعي وهي اليوم تحاول ان تكون واقعيه
اكثر في مقاربه القاره الافريقيه نحن
راينا رفضا كبيرا للوجود العسكري الفرنسي
في افريقيا بعد اكثر من 50 او 60 عاما على
استقلال هذه البلدان ورغم ان دعوه وجود
الارهاب في هذه القاره وفي بعض البلدان
الافريقيه يستدعي الوجود الفرنسي مرفوضه
تماما خاصه من قبل الجيل الشاب في عدد من
البلدان الافريقيه ان لم يكن معظمها وهذا
الجيل الشاب هو من يحاول ان يخاطبه ومن
ضمن الخطاب كان هناك توجه نحو الشباب ايضا
بالقول ان فرنسا ستدفع اموالا للمشاريع
الصغيره
ستستثمر في القاره وستدفع اموالا على شكل
هبات للمشاريع الصغيره وللنهوض بالاقتصاد
الافريقي وايضا سيقر قانونا يعيد كل القطع
الفنيه التي نهبت من افريقيا خلال فتره
الاستعمار طبعا موقف موقف ماكرون اضعف من
موقف روسيا والصين وغيرها لان لدى فرنسا
تركه استعماريه لم يعني يتم التغاضي عنها
لغايه اليوم ولم يتم فتح ملفاتها كلها
مصيده مكرون الافريقيه كتاب مصيده ماكرون
الافريقيه سمى ذلك بان خلاصه القول هي ان
فرنسا لم تقدر حجم هذا الماضي الذي لا يمر
ولكن روسيا لا تحرض حاليا على مشاعر
معاديه بل تستغل هذا الاستياء يعني كامر
واقع استاذه هدى ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لك
صحفيه السياسيه من باريس تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في الملف الاوكراني نجح رهان الصين في ربط
اسمها بمبادره للحل بدلا من ربطه دائما
بمساعده روسيا عسكريا المبادره ذات البنود
ذا الاثني عشر اخذت نصيبها من الجدل وان
كانت لم تحظى برفض او قبول قاطعين من اي
من الاطراف لكن قريبا لن تكون مبادره
الصين وحدها على الساحه فبحسب صحيفه بلد
الالمانيه يضغط الحلفاء على كييف من اجل
الاستعداد لمباحثات مع موسكو والمقاربه
واضحه امام كياف الفرصه لتحقيق تقدم كبير
بحلول الخريف يساعدها على التفاوض الامر
اذا اشبه بانذار عسكري ليزالنسكي والكلام
لصحيفه بنت
طعام من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه توسطت
فيه كافه الاطراف الدوليه لوقف الحرب الا
انها لم تنجح لتعرض الصين في ذكرى الاولى
للحرب خططا ب 12 بندا باحلال السلام بين
الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي
وصف المبادره الصينيه بانها تستحق
الاهتمام منتقدا لظروف الراهنه التي تحول
دون تنفيذها
اننا ننظر في خطه اصدقاءنا الصينيين
باهتمام كبير انها عمليه طويله في الوقت
الراهن لا نرى الظروف التي من شانها ان
تضع هذه القضيه على مسار سلمي العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره
[موسيقى]
رحبت بحذر بالخطه
مع فضي على بعض البنود وزيلينسكي اكد ان
فكره توسط الحليف في روسيا في السلام امر
مبشر
من الصواب الاعتقاد بانه اذا كانت هناك
افكار تتوافق بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام
القانون الدولي وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع
الصين في هذه النقطه
كما انه عبر عن رغبته بلقاء نظيره الصيني
لمناقشه العمليات العسكريه والعلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
تتخذ الصين موقفا واضحا للغايه وثابتا من
الازمه الاوكرانيه نحن على اتصالا مع جميع
الاطراف المعنيه بما في ذلك اوكرانيا
الغربيه متفاوته قابلت المبادره الصينيه
بعضها كان مشجعا والاخر كان مشككا اما في
الولايات المتحده فقد شككت المخابرات
والبانتاجون بدور الصين بينما ترك البيت
الابيض الباب مفتوحا حول مساهمه بكين
بالحل لكن الابرز هي تسريبات صحفيه عن
توجه غربي للضغط على كييف للقبول
بالمفاوضات خلال اشهر وعمر العربيه
من برلين معنا ماريا يونوفا عضو لجنه شؤون
الخارجيه في البرلمان الاوكراني اهلا بك
معنا في العربيه 360 الى اي مدى
تعتقدين بصوابيه هذا الخيار الذي وضعت
اوكرانيا امام الان تحقيق تقدم قبل الخريف
او الاجبار على التفاوض
اسعد الله مساءكم لابد لي في البدايه ان
اشدد على حقيقه مفادها ان
هذا النظام النظام الرسوي الروسي يقوم كل
يوم بقتل اطفالنا ويقوم باطلاق الصواريخ
على بلادنا ولابد لنا ان نعمل على حمايه
بلادنا
النقطه الثانيه هي اننا نثمن
الموقف الروسي
والصين هي دوله دائمه العضويه في مجلس
الامن
وهذا المقترح الذي تم نقله
الرئاسه في بلادنا لكن الصين انتهكت
الكثير من الاعراف والقوانين لذا لا اعتقد
ان الراي السائد والمشترك بان الذي تم
الحديث عنه بين روسيا والصين بانه سوف يتم
قبول هذه المقابله ثالثا هناك خطه رمزيه
قدمتها الصين
في تاريخ الدخول اليوم الاول للعام
لمضي سنه واحده للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا ايضا وفقا لبعض المستندات
والتصريحات فاننا نرى
ان هناك النوايا
من قبل بيجين
التي ساهمت في اطلاق بعض في اطلاق سراح
بعض الرهائن فهذا النطاق
قد قد يكون مثار جدل الى حد كثير اذ ان
المقترح لا يمكن ان يتم قبوله او رفض كليا
لكن نرى بانه من الضروري ان نشرك الصين في
اي حوار وكما ذكر الرئيس كيف اننا نسعى ان
نتخذ مسار الدبلوماسيه
باي شكل من الاشكال دون ان تكون هناك اي
حاله من التوتر ولكن انظري معنا الى بعض
الاخبار العاجله لو تكرمت رئيس بيلاروسيا
يقول الان لا خيار امام كييف الا
لا خيار امامك الان سوى ابرام معاهده سلام
بدون شروط مسبقه ومدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه قبل قليل قال الرئيس الصيني امر
بوضع خطط لاستعاده تايوان في عشرين سبعه
وعشرين البعض يقول انه الوقت بات يمكن ان
يدرككم قريبا من سيتمكن من دعمكم كل هذا
الدعم في الغرب اذا بدات حرب استعاده
تايوان كما تسميها الصين
الاوكرانيون
يرغبون بتحقيق السلام
وادراكا منهم بانهم دفعوا ثمنا باهظا
كبيرا ويستمرون بدفع كل يوم والان يبدو ان
الخيار على خلفيه كل هذه الاحداث هو ان
يستمروا في الحرب وسوق الكلمه الاخيره
لميدان المعركه وهذه الحرب
قد تستمر لسنوات طويله ويؤسفني ان اقول ان
دولا كثيره كانت تنظر الى الحقيقه باعين
مغمضه وغير صادقه لكن
لكنهم لم يصدقوا ان عمليه الحرب الكامله
التي تمت قد تم الاكتفاء بها بمجرد فرض
العقوبات على روسيا
واننا ننظر
الى كيفيه
قيام العالم المتحضر بابداء الردود افعال
وكيف يمكنهم التغاضي عما تقوم به روسيا من
انتهاك لجرائم واقترافي اعمال جرميه مثل
الاغتصاب كسلاح حرب وغيرها
لابد لنا ان نقوم باعاده القانون الدولي
ليكون هو السائد لذا فان العداله من حقي
الجانب الاوكراني اذ ان روسيا تقوم بالقتل
والغصب والتعذيب
ولا بد لها من تحمل المسؤوليه عن كافه
تصرفاتها
لان لانه عندما تسود العداله وعندما تقوم
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بالنظر في هذه
الموضوع فيمكنه عند ذلك ان يسود النظام
العالمي
تبقينا معنا لو تكرمت ماريا يونوفا ونعود
اليك بعد قليل طبعا روسيا ترد على هذه
الاتهامات فيها جمله وتفصيلا وتتهم الجانب
الاوكراني بالقيام بهذه الجرائم من خلال
جماعات
نازيه متطرفه كما تصفها ونستعرض الان
الجانب البلاروسي من الموضوع قبل ان نعود
اليك بيلاروسيا تستعد للدخول بشكل مباشر
في الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن بشروط بحسب
السلطات في منسك مسؤول رفيع المستوى في
بيلاروسيا قال ان الدول ان الدول
المتحالفه او الدوله المتحالفه مع روسيا
والمجاوره لاوكرانيا اي بيلاروسيا لديها
ما يصل الى مليون وخمسمائه الفرد وهم
جاهزون للقتال خارج قواتها المسلحه وكاله
بلتا للانباء نسبت الى سكرتير مجلس الامن
البيلاروسي الكزامدر فولفوفيتش قوله ان
هذا العدد منفصل عن الجيش وانه سيوضع رهن
الخدمه في حاله اعلان الاحكام العرفيه
ووضع الاقتصاد في حاله الح وبحسب تقرير
التوازن العسكري الصادر عن المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه يصل قوام الجيش في
بيلاروسيا الى نحو 48 الف جندي اضافه في
حرس الحدود في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر امر
الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاتشينكو
بتشكيل قوه دفاع بريه جديده تضم متطوعين
قد تضم ما يقارب 150 الف شخص واكد
لوكاتشينكو ان جيش بلاده لم يحارب الا اذا
هجمت بيلاروسيا ويدعم رئيس بيلاروسيا
نظيره الروسي في حربه على اوكرانيا
المستمره منذ عام وسمح له بشن عمليات ضد
اوكرانيا انطلاقا من اراضي بيلاروسيا فضلا
عن تدريب قوات حشدت مؤخرا داخل البلاد
بيلاروسيا نفت اليوم عبر اداره الحدود صحه
الانباء عن تبادل لاطلاق النار يوم السبت
الماضي على الحدود مع اوكرانيا واشارت
الاداره الى ان المعلومات التي ينشرها من
وصفتهم بالمتطرفين لا علاقه لها بالواقع
ومع التوتر الذي يسود الحدود بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا اعلنت الاخيره نيتها
توسيع عمق الشريط الحدودي المزروع
بالالغام على طول الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
وروسيا حتى مسافه كيلومترين من جانبها
اعلنت بيلاروسيا استعدادها التام للرد على
اي استفزاز المحتمل من الجانب الاوكراني
على حد وصف سلطات
واليوم اكد الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر ان
بامكان مينسك وموسكو انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه وبكميات كافيه على الرغم من
العقوبات اشاد لوكتشينكو بفضل روسيا التي
قال انها تزود بلاده بما يكفي من موده
اوليه لصنع ما يكفي من المعدات العسكريه
لي
الرئيس البيلاروسي قال ايضا ان منتجات
الاسلحه في بلاده يمكن تصديرها الى اكثر
من 50 دوله خاصه وان بيلاروسيا بحسب
رئيسها تنتج انواعا حديثه من الاسلحه
المطلوبه عالميا كاواريخ وذخيره المدفعيه
ذات العيار الثقيل
[موسيقى]
اود الاشاره الى انه على الرغم من ضغوط
العقوبات غير المسبوقه فاننا ننتج اسلحه
ومعدات عسكريه كافيه لاحتياجات الجيش
البيلاروسي ويرجع ذلك الى ان كل ما نحتاجه
من الاسلحه والحديد نحصل عليه بسهوله من
روسيا فيما يتعلق بالالكترونيات الدقيقه
والالكترونيات الضوئيه والبصريات وغيرها
فالفضل لاولئك الذين حافظوا على مرافق
الانتاج الموروثه من الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
بامكاننا مع روسيا انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه
الان رغم التحالف الوثيقه بين روسيا
وبيلاروسيا الذي تحدثنا عنه الا ان وثائق
مسربه قبل ايام من الكرملين اظهرت ان
موسكو تخطط للسيطره الكامله على حليفتها
منسك في اطار انشاء مشروع روسيا العظمى
الجديده وفقا لما نشرته صحيفه تيليجراف
البريطانيه مشروع الكلام للسيطره على
بيلاروسيا بحسب وسائل علم غربيه قائم منذ
ما يقرب من 24 عاما وكان ينظر للمشروع
المسمى دوله الاتحاد على انه اتفاقيه تقوم
على المصالح المشتركه مع ذلك اشارت
الوثيقه الى ان روسيا تواصل توسيع وجودها
العسكري في بيلاروسيا حتى يصبح دائما وعلى
ان تمتثل القوات المسلحه البيلاروسيه
لللوائح الروسيه واشارت التسريبات الى ان
الكرم لن يسعى لتوحيد اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
كجزء من روسيا الاتحاديه واشار سفير
الولايات المتحده لدى منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا الى ان اهداف روسيا مع
بيلاروسيا مماثله لاهدافها مع اوكرانيا
الا ان الفارقه الوحيد انها في بيلاروسيا
تعتمد على الاكراه وليس الحرب كما هو
الحال في اوكرانيا التوتر مع روسيا يمتد
ايضا الى اين مولدوفا الجاره الجنوبيه
لاوكرانيا قبل ايام نشرت صحيفه جاردين
البريطانيه تقريرا تحدث عن ضروره ان يتنبه
الغرب للهجمات غير المباشره التي تشنها
روسيا على مولدوفا اضافت الصحيفه ان
مولدوفا بحاجه الى المساعده الغربيه لوجود
مؤشرات على استعداد روسيا لاستهداف جارات
اوكرانيا الاستراتيجيه مع استبعاد
الاجتياح المباشر والاعتماد على اسلوب
اثاره الاضطرابات ومطلع الشهر الجاري
استقالت الحكومه المولدوفيه المقربه من
اوروبا بعد اضطرابات اتهمت موسكو بتدميرها
وفق اجهزه الاستخبارات الغربيه خاصه في
الانفصاليه المواليه لموسكو والتي تنتشر
فيها وحده عسكريه روسيه بشكل عام تتعرض
مولدوفا لهجمات الكترونيه وهجمت اعلاميه
روسيه كما اغلقت البلاد مجالها الجوي في
الايام الماضيه بعد تحذيرات امنيه
تعود الينا من برلين ماريا يونوفا عضو
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني اهلا بك معنا مره جديده استاذه
يونوفا واسالك هنا عن احقيه عن ردك على من
يقول باحقيه روسيا بضم دول اخرى حليفه لها
في هذه الحرب وفي هذه الحاله نتحدث عن
بيلاروسيا بما ان حلف النيتو
بقبضه وقديده وقضيده يساعد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح بالمال وبوتين قالها صراحه بالامس
حلف الناتو منخره مباشره وليس بشكل غير
مباشر بهذه الحرب
كيف تردون
فان روسيا قد انتهت
بيلاروسيا لا يمكن
ان تكون دوله مختلفه عن روسيا فقدت سمحت
لروسيا ان تستخدم اراضيها لتشنج هجمات من
هناك وهناك جنود نظاميون روس على الاراضي
البيلاروسيه ودعونا لا ننسى الثوره التي
كانت قد اطاحت
بالنظام السابق في بيلاروسيا
وكم حدث من انتهاكات هناك بحق حقوق
الانسان ومالدوفا لابد من الاشاره اليها
ولكن هذه الانتهاكات التي يقوم بها بوتين
هي ليست حديثه العهد بل تتم في بلدان
بصوره مستمره
وهذا يطال كوسافو وبيلاروس
وكافه
مناطق اخرى في العالم لذا لابد من وجود
حاله من الوحده العالميه من اجل وقف عدوان
بوتين على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ومساعده
بلادنا اليوم
لانه لدينا خيار واحد فقط هو ان نبقى على
قيد الحياه ان نحارب وان ندافع عن بلادنا
وندافع عن شعبنا لان روسيا سوف تتمادى
وبوتين
وكما جاء على الذكر بانه يرغب بان يعيد
حدود الاتحاد السوفيتي سابق وهذه وهذا
تفكير مجنون
لذا
الديمقراطيه
لا بد لها
من خلال دولا التي تنادي بهذا الشعار ان
تقدم العون بالسلاح ونحن لابد لنا ان نعمل
مع دول اخرى
التي قد تكون عرضه او يحتمل ان تكون
عرضه لاي عدوان روسي من اجل
من اجل العمل على طردي حتى روسيا من عضويه
مجلس الامن وان تتحل ان
ان تتحمل روسيا مسؤوليه كافه الجرائم نفو
عمليه التطهير العرقي التي تقوم به
والاباده الجماعيه لان هذه مساله تخص
مستقبل واجيال في دول اخرى وفي العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك ماريا في البرلمان
الاوروبيه وطبعا حق الرد محفوظ لمن يود من
المسؤولين والمحللين والصحفيين الرسل
حضرت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا
بيربوك من ان قدره مجلس حقوق الانسان في
جنيف باتت محدوده في حمايه المدنيين في
اوكرانيا وايران
هناك اطفال اختطفتهم روسيا من خرسون يجب
فتح تحقيق في كل حاله على حده ومحاسبه
مرتكبي جرائم اختطاف الاطفال في اوكرانيا
اصبحت قوتنا لحمايه المدنيين في اوكرانيا
وايران محدوده في نوفمبر الماضي اتخذ
المجلس قرارا بفتح تحقيق دولي فيما حدث
بايران بعد قتل مئات الاطفال والنساء
والمحتاجين ولم يتم تنفيذه حتى الان ويجب
وقف هذا القمع
غدر عدد من المشاركين في اجتماع الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان في جنيف الجلسه
خلال القاء وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبدالله هيان كلمته
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا اردوغان يقر
بالتقصير في الزلزال ومهمه صعبه تنتظره 70
مليار دولار لاعاده الاعمار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قدر البنك الدولي اضرار
زلزال السادس من فبراير في تركيا بنحو
اربعه
وثلاثين.2 مليار دولار مؤكدا ان كلفه
اعاده الاعمار ستكون اعلى بمرتين وانها
ستخفض نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بمقدار
نصف نقطه مئويه خلال العام الحالي
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان طلب الصفح من
شعبها بسبب الاستجابه المتاخره لكارثه
الزلزال
بعد الزلزال المدمر كان هناك طقس بارد
وصعب جدا في الايام الاولى ربما لم نتمكن
من العمل كما كان يلزم بسبب صعوبه الظروف
لذلك اتمنى منكم المسامحه ونحن الان على
يقين باننا سنقوم بكل ما يلزم من اجل
مواجهه هذه التحديات
هذا وضرب زلزال جديد بقوه خمس درجات وسته
اعشار النقطه على مقياس تركيا ما ادى الى
مقتل شخص واصابه العشرات جراء انهيار مبان
في ملاطيا واوضحت السلطات ان مركز الزلزال
بمقاطعه ملاطيا وعلى عمق سبعه كيلومترات
وصفتنا النشاط الزلزاليه الاخير في
المنطقه بغير المعتاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلال استقباله نظيره المصري في مرسين قال
وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش انه من
المحتمل العقد لقاء بين الرئيسين التركي
والمصري قريبا بينما ذكرت مصادر للعربيه
ان اردوغان سيزور القاهره في ابريل المقبل
نقوم بفتح صفحات جديده مع مصر وسنعمل على
نقل العلاقات مع القاهره الى مستوى اعلى
في الاونه الاخيره كانت هناك مباحثات بين
الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس السيسي وتبحث
اليوم مع سامح شكري بشان الخطوات التي
علينا اتخاذها لتطوير العلاقات بين بلدينا
وتطور العلاقات التركيه المصريه سيؤثر
ايجابا على المنطقه باكملها
وكان وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري اكد
انه يحمل رساله تضامن لتركيا بعد الزلزال
انا محمل رساله
تضامن ومؤازره ومواساه الى الشعب التركي
الصديق
على مستوى القياده
والحكومه والشعب المصري
لهذا المصاب وهذه الكارثه التي تالمنا
جميعا
لوقعها
نعمل بكل ما لدينا من جهد لمؤازره اخواتنا
واخواتنا في
تركيا
لتجاوز هذه المحنه
وكان شكري زار تركيا قادما من دمشق حيث
التقى الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد من اجل
نقل رساله تضامن من مصر واعرب الاسد عن
شكره للقاهره على ما قدمته من مساعدات
مؤكدا حرصه دمشق على العلاقات الثنائيه
بينما اكد شكري ان الهدف من زيارته انساني
بالدرجه الاولى
قولي له مكانته لدى الشعب المصري والهدف
من هذه الزياره هو هدف في المقام الاول
الانساني لنقل التضامن على مستوى القياده
والمستوى الحكومه ومستوى الشعب المصري
للشعب السوري مصور في هذه المحن نحن
نتعامل على ارضيه ما يربطنا من اواصل
انسانيه هذا هو ما نركز عليه في المرحله
الحاليه
نعلم من القاهره مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
اهلا بك معنا احمد هل من تفاصيل او
معلومات اضافيه حول طبيعه العلاقه في
المرحله المقبله زيارات المتبادله على اي
مستوى المواعيد ما الذي اعتم الاتفاق عليه
كي
تكون هذه الزيارات الان وفي المستقبل
القريب
يعني حتى الان ربما كان هناك الاتفاق على
يعني استئناف العلاقات بشكل مكثف خلال
المرحله المقبله ربما اذا بدانا فيما
يتعلق بزياره تركيا تحديدا فان هناك حديث
عن زياره مرتقبه كما ذكرت انت وذكرت
المصادر للعربيه لانها قد تكون في شهر
ابريل المقبل ربما بعد نهايه شهر رمضان
ربما هذه المصادر اكدت بان الزياره قد
تكون استقبال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في القاهره خلال هذه الفتره مرحله
ما بعد العيد يعني هذه ربما مواعيد مبدئيه
سيتم تحديد المواعيد بشكل نهائي خلال
المرحله المقبله ولكن بشكل عام هناك من
يرى بان تحركات القاهره التي تاتي في اطار
ربما ما عرف خلال الايام او الاسابيع
الماضيه بانعم دبلوماسيه ما بعد الزلزال
على الرغم من ان العناوين الرئيسيه
للزيارتين تحمل طياتها المؤازره الانسانيه
في اعقاب كارثه الزلزال ولكن هناك من يرى
بان الزلزال في حد ذاته والانفتاح ما بين
القاهره وانقره وان كان قد سبقته عدد من
المشاهد ومنها اللقاء الذي تم على هامش
افتتاح كاس العالم في الدوحه في نوفمبر
الماضي ما بين الرئيس السيسي والرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وايضا فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات المصريه السوريه وان كان هناك
من يرى بان كان هناك هامش من القاتل ربما
على المستوى الامني خلال الفتره الماضيه
ولكن كل هذه الامور يتم ربطها بشكل مباشر
بعمليه الانفتاح العربي التي تمت خلال
الايام الماضيه من خلال
جلسه رؤساء البرلمان العرب في بغداد
وبتلاها الى زياره الى دمشق هناك من يرى
بان هناك سياق عربي جديد فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقه مع دمشق ربما تتضح معالمها خلال
المرحله المقبله ومن ثم فان تحركات
القاهره تاتي في هذا السياق وسيكون هناك
الك ثير ربما من الزيارات الاكثر والتي قد
تحمل عناوين غير الزلزال خلال الايام او
الاسابيع المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك احمد
عثمان مراسل العربيه من القاهره تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا البيت الابيض يقول ان السعوديه تقوم
بخطوات كبيره لدعم استقرار المنطقه ويتحدث
ايضا عن ترحيبه بزياره وزير خارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل من فرحان الى
اوكرانيا وبنتائجها كذلك بعد مفاوضات شاقه
اكدت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه توصل
لاتفاق جديد مع لندن حول ايرلندا الشماليه
يناسب كل الاطراف
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
ويضيف البيت الابيض ان السعوديه شريك
استراتيجي لامريكا منذ ثمانيه عقود وفي
موضوعنا السابق اكد رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه اما الاتفاق يحمي سياده
ايرلندا الشماليه ويمثل صفحه جديده من
العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
اتفاقنا اليوم مع الاتحاد الاوروبي يحمي
سياده ايرلندا الشماليه ويمنع وضع حدود
بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا
بما يؤول الى ازاله كل عقبات نقل البضائع
التجاريه بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه
ايرلندا كما نود الاشاره الى انه سيتم
تطبيق قانون الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا
الشماليه لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره
وازاله اي حدود بحريه في البحر الايرلندي
بشان العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
بريطانيا فتحت صفحه جديده في العلاقات معه
في العربيه 360 ايضا امطار في ملاعب تركيا
من اجل اطفال الزلزال امطار من الالعاب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ابدا منسق الامم المتحده
الخاص لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
قلقه الشديد ازاءه تدهور الاوضاع في الضفه
الغربيه وغرد قائلا ان قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه تتحمل مسؤوليه الحفاظ على
الامن ومنع الافراد من تطبيق القانون
بايديهم داعيا الى توقف كل اشكال التحريض
فورا
هذا واعتبرت الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان اعمال
العنف ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين غير مقبوله
وقالت انها تدين بشده الهجمات التي تسفر
عن مقتل اسرائيليين وكذلك اعمال العنف ضد
المدنيين الفلسطينيين من جهتها اكدت
المانيا ضروره تجنب تصعيد الوضع المتوتر
اصلا
والبيت الابيض يقول للعربيه ان العنف
الجاري يدفعنا للعمل لاجل السلام بين
الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
محمد شتيه كان دعا لتفعيل لجان الحمايه
الشعبيه للتصدي للمستوطنين محملا تل ابيب
المسؤوليه كامله عن احداث بلده حواره
وهنا ادعو الى تفعيل عمل لجاني الحمايه
الشعبيه في كل مكان وعلى ضوء الجرائم
البشعه التي ارتكبها المستعمرون الفاشيون
وبتوجيه من وزراء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فاننا نحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل
المسؤوليه عن جرائم المستوطنين في حواره
وبقيه الكره المحيطه وسوف يضاف هذا
الاجرام الى ملف محاكمه اسرائيل في
المحاكم الدوليه وعليه فاننا سنقوم بتشكيل
لجنه وزاريه من وزاره الحكم المحلي
والماليه ومحافظ نابلس
للوقوف على الاضرار التي لحقت باهلنا هناك
لغرض المساهمه في تعويضهم
من جاته قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه
يتوقع اياما صعبه بعد احداث العنف الاخيره
وربما ايام الصعبه قد يحدث هذا في الضفه
الغربيه في القدس او في غزه اعطيت تعليمات
واضحه للجيش الاسرائيلي وجهاز الامن العام
وشرطه حرس الحدود للاستعداد الكامل
لمواجهه جميع التهديدات من خلال زياده
النشاط في الميدان واضافه القوات والعناصر
لحمايه المستوطنات والطرق
واليوم قتل مستوطن متاثرا بجروحه بعد حادث
اطلاق نار في محيط اريحا بالضفه الغربيه
وقالت القوات الاسرائيليه ان منفذي الحادث
منفذي الحادث سحابه باتجاه المدينه وانها
تواصل عمليات البحث عنهما
في الاثناء حذرت 22 خبيرا اسرائيليا في
القانون الدولي في رساله للنائب العام
حذروا من ان هجمات المستوطنين على بلدات
بالضفه الغربيه ترقى لجرائم حرب ودعا
الخبراء لتحقيق فوري في تلك الممارسات
متهمين قاده اقصى اليمين بالتحريض على
العنف
لكن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو قال ان حكومته ستقنن وضع
المستوطنات التي ظلت غير شرعيه لسنوات
طويله مضيفا ان حكومته ستبني الاف المنازل
في المستوطنات كرد على الهجمات التي يتعرض
لها المستوطنون على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 القرن باتت
جزءا لا يتجزا من روسيا التصريح للمتحدث
باسم الكرملين
الى اوكرانيا تعد امرا مستحيلا وجاءت
تصريحات بسكوب ردا على تصريحات غربيه
اوضحها من الرئيس اوضحها اتى من الرئيس
الامريكي عن امكانيه عوده المنطقه لسيطره
وفقا لاتفاقيات مستقبليه وبموجيب الوقت
فيديو اليوم من اسطنبول التركيه في مباراه
لكره القدم القت الجماهير الاف الالعاب
الى ارضيه الملعب من اجل ايصالها للاطفال
المتضررين من الزلزال في الجنه
سوره اليوم من ضخمه الاوكرانيه لجنديه
يستغل فتره راحته لمداعبه اوتارك بيانو او
ما تبقى منه بحثا عن صوت مختلف عن صوت
القنابل
نذكركم بخبر في عن لاعب باريس سان جيرمان
اشرف حكيمي يخضع للتحقيق في باريس بتهمه
الاغتصاب نكتفي بهذا القدر في العربيه 360
ونتابع ملفات العربيه مع صهيب شراير في
اخبار الساعه الان صهيب ماذا لديك مساء
الخير طاهر المزيد من الاخبار العاجله
اخرها الخارجيه الامريكيه تعتبر الخطه
الصينيه للسلام في اوكرانيا بانها قد تكون
غير جديه والبيت الابيض يشيد بالدعم
السعودي لاوكرانيا تفضل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]